is unveiling his plan to dramatically
overhaul america's immigration system
and roll back
trump policies the proposal creates a
pathway to citizenship
for nearly 11 million undocumented
people and does not include additional
money for border security
republicans warning it will create a
surge of illegal immigration and lead to
quote
blanket amnesty that is happening while
a new caravan is on the move in central
america a group of migrants has already
made its way
to mexico katie i noticed yesterday that
or this morning there's a
conservative coalition that's coming
together heritage action judicial crisis
network
and americans for public trust they're
launching a combined two million dollar
ad campaign like they had done before
for conservative
uh judges that they were supporting in
this case they're actually
running ads about some of joe biden's
nominees including
xavier becerra from california he's been
a real champion
uh for decriminalizing illegal
immigration
uh he's of course up for hhs secretary
the politics of this aside from the
merits of it the politics of this are
going to get
very difficult for the biden
administration pretty quickly i think
but would love your thoughts
yeah on so many different levels i mean
there's the pandemic
issue there's this issue of unemployment
and people trying to get back on their
feet at a time when businesses were
devastated last year
the issue of not adding more border
security
shows that the democrats in the biden
white house really aren't interested in
working
with with republicans on this they know
that they have the majority in the house
and the senate and they want to move
forward
with this amnesty that they've talked
about for years and years and it's not
11 million people it's more like
20 million people and the reason why
republicans always say there has to be a
border security component to this
is because if you don't do that you
create a magnet and now we're already
seeing border patrol agents saying that
they've seen a doubling
of unaccompanied minors under the age of
in the past couple of weeks so they're
creating a crisis
on a number of different levels and i
think we're just seeing the beginning of
it
jesse one of the things they did is they
the white house is now saying please
don't rush the border but they also
ended the remaining mexico policy so
it's almost like saying
um you know we're not going to check ids
at disneyland and admission is free but
please don't come
yeah well at least they said please
they're so polite dana it's
it's just it's so refreshing this bill
that they've proposed is fake it's
designed to fail there's no way
it clears the senate and they did that
on purpose so when the republicans take
back the house or the senate
democrats can say republicans are
blocking immigration
and they can campaign on it it's the
same thing all politicians do they don't
solve a problem
and they just blame the other party for
that problem
even the politico came out and said this
is terrible politics and policy
they have an article that says this
thing's a recipe for disaster
and it's littered with quotes from
democrats on the border and swing states
saying blanket amnesty open borders
we're going to lose our seats
and politico even says you're already
seeing migrants come into these border
towns
and they're just overwhelming the health
care system and the small businesses
ap reports now the panama government
they basically opened their border and
now migrants are flowing out of the
colombian jungle
up through central america and the
central american governments are saying
hey come on through
as a shakedown so joe sends them more
foreign aid
which of course they pocket i want to
just address this 11 million number
i've been at fox since 2003 i used to be
a producer before they put makeup on me
we used to do research packets
how many illegals in this country in
2003 dana it was 11 million
you're saying nearly 20 years later that
number's still 11 million
no no no no it's at least 20 million and
everybody knows it
one sometimes white houses decide to let
congress
write the legislation so that they can
kind of have a hands-off
approach that's not what this white
house is doing they're actually writing
the legislation and sending it up
and are they heading right into a
political buzz saw
well i i don't see that this is going to
pass as a comprehensive bill dana
if the buzz saw on that level but i must
say when i was looking at it it looked
i mean basically it's the same bill as
the bill that got bipartisan support in
2013. remember
it got 68 votes in the senate so it was
like 14
republicans back the bill but i think
what we're
seeing now is that clearly this issue
has to be seen through the lens
of the last four years of donald trump
and i think republicans have become
more aggressive less open to immigration
and democrats meanwhile have been saying
hey
what about this hostility to immigrants
we want to make sure that we are
standing up for immigrants
and you get into like silly arguments do
you call them illegal immigrants or do
you call them undocumented you know what
that's all
show it's all theater the reality is it
doesn't solve the problem
so i think what biden's best chance is
to avoid your buzz saw dana is to do
things in pieces like to go about the
dreamers to look at e-verify
to look at border security and then the
toughest
nugget is going to be dealing with the
people who are already here and have
been here and live in our communities
craig i don't know if that's i don't
know if the that's accurate in terms of
the politics if it's just
simply a republican versus democrat
issue i think that there were one of the
reasons that president trump
got more hispanic and latino votes in
2020 than he did in 2016 was partly
because of the focus on the economy and
you'd seen wages
go up uh for lots of different reasons
including
this one yeah you answered your own
question thank you i'm pretty good at
that yes um
uh there was a bottom line standard that
trump had he was pro-american worker
and that means that obviously makes him
seem harsh to the immigrant but he has
to
if he's going to make a choice he has to
choose that but you in the in the front
end of your question you talked about
the politics of this
and that's the problem we the reason why
we keep getting into these dead ends is
because we
look at immigration as a political
variable
when it's an economic variable i.e the
american worker
that's an economic variable uh so you so
you would moderate the flow of the
immigrants based on the changing
circumstances of your economy
so right now we have millions of
unemployed american workers
we have lives that have been destroyed
by a pandemic we have an education
system that is a mess
our health care system is stressed um
this seems a point when you look at the
when you look at the switches for
immigration that you would turn it back
and wait a little while
and then when the country is backed to a
time of great growth and the ec
the economy is exploding and the
population is healthy
and there is a surplus of jobs you can
then you know turn the toggle back up
for uh immigrants so the the thing is i
think we run into a problem when
when it's always politics but if you if
you switch it to economics
and people might say that's cold oh how
can you put it in the cold world of
economics
economics is the only way to measure the
benefits and consequences of a policy
you know when people are doing bad by
looking at the economics how much money
they're taking home
how much how much money they have for
food so that's the only way you can
measure it
that's why trump was right and you're
going to find out a lot of this stuff
in hindsight trump turned out to be way
ahead of it he was ahead of me on this
i disagreed with him all right